hi I'm Kurt Braunohler we don't a lot in
time so these are three thousand things
absurdist love let's go doll heads
releasing seagulls at a wedding slicing
up eyeballs giving people regular names
as nicknames hey Seymour some best
friend Tim repetition doing magic tricks
that aren't magic wipes a quarter watch
the quarter watch the quarter where is
it going
wing-dings the best way to say I love
you
repetition grunting while doing math
sitting weird drive by sandwiching
Hakuna Matata asking football players
how's the water pipes in general talking
to someone without looking at them
repetition with slight variation
children's museums what are they they're
museums to children but there's children
everywhere screaming god bless you
hey Logan how you doing the statue wants
kissing your own hand instead of the
person you're greeting pleasure to meet
you
pooping and egg out your mouth this
isn't my house giving animals titles
Adventure time spelling things with hot
dogs bringing a balloons to a Funeral
aunt hands
did I say repetition yeah repetition is
definitely one